foreign
each day more companies are reevaluating
the best place to run their applications
and many are making moves to different
Cloud providers
moving your load balance deployment to a
different location whether you're on
Prem or already in the cloud is time
consuming and can come with a slew of
challenges that's why we put together a
jumpstart solution to simplify the
process of migrating your existing load
balance implementation to Google cloud
in just a few minutes
if you're joining Google cloud or
thinking about it you likely have
existing applications that you'd like to
find a destination for and could use
some advice on how to do that simply and
quickly
you may be wishing that you could have
an easy way to duplicate your
infrastructure into Google Cloud without
having to deal with the learning curve
of mastering every new acronym product
or script you run into
or you might be happy with how your
infrastructure is set up and you want to
be able to automate rebuilding on our
platform without having to deal with
restructuring or modernizing it first
which is often required when moving well
we hear you and that's why we put
together this solution to meet you at
this point in your journey it'll help
you understand and practice implementing
and using load balanced virtual machines
on Google Cloud without any
restructuring or previous Google Cloud
knowledge necessary our solution creates
a virtual machine cluster with a load
balancer makes VMS globally available
and scales to automatically and easily
manage traffic and regulate your
application's health all of this with a
few clicks in a matter of about 10
minutes
by the end of your interaction with the
solution you'll better understand how to
apply this knowledge to your own web
apps
apis for mobile and web applications
proprietary or Specialized Service
applications
vendor applications and yes even your
legacy applications
so let's dive into how the solution
works and what it looks like on the back
end
the existing solution is a
terraform-based script that installs a
static content web application using
nginx
each node of the managed instance group
writes its name into its copy of the
static Source allowing you to see the
application Bounce from instance to
instance as the page is Reloaded
Google Cloud load balancer is used for
high performance scalable load balancing
along with compute engine as a secure
and customizable compute service that
lets you create and run virtual machines
on Google Cloud's infrastructure when a
user makes a request to the application
via the public IP address managed by
Google Cloud load balancer traffic is
distributed to one of the VM instances
managed by the compute engine managed
instance Group which scales the number
of instances based on traffic volume or
node health
with just a few clicks this jumpstart
solution will deploy all of the
necessary resources created and
configured by Google Cloud
there is a slight delay between when the
deployed status shows up for the
solution to when the load balancer is
all ready to go so just give it a little
time to do its job
once deployed you'll be able to see the
VMS the load balancer configuration
monitoring and cache details and the
application site that is served by those
VMS each time you reload the page you'll
see the different VM that is serving up
that particular page
using this application through the
console is best to try out the solution
and see how it works with all the
backend work of resource deployment done
for you
there's a quick and simple way to become
more knowledgeable on duplicating your
infrastructure on Google Cloud
alternatively you can also download the
solution as terraform from GitHub to
deploy yourself later
if you run into any issues or want more
information make sure to check out the
solution guide as your helpful resource
it includes answers to common questions
that may come up recommendations on how
to view the resources that were deployed
like the compute engine instances and
the load balancer plus troubleshooting
tips in case something doesn't go as
planned
and there you have it a solution
developed to teach you a quick and
simple way to create load balanced
virtual machines on Google Cloud that
you can then translate to your own
implementation now keep in mind that
this solution is meant to show you the
ropes and help you explore the
capabilities of Google Cloud but it
should not be used as is for production
environments
check out the links in the description
to try out this jumpstart solution now
[Music]
thank you